ce container est un simulateur
d'incendiés alimentés en bois il produit
un type de feu très spécifiques
auxquelles les sapeurs pompiers sont
souvent confrontés un équipement unique
en haute saône dans lequel quatorze
jeunes pompiers en formation s'entraîne
pour la première fois c'est très
important puisque on appréhende déjà
beaucoup plus le danger et on apprend à
avoir les signes avant coureurs des
phénomènes thermiques justement lors des
récents
ce site aux portes de vesoul a pendant
longtemps été un centre technique et de
maintenance des véhicules grâce à un
agrandissement et à de nouvelles
constructions
il est devenu le centre de formation des
pompiers de haute saône
ici les pompiers peuvent s'entraîner sur
des équipements adaptés si on est en
capacité de former les 1900 sapeurs
pompiers de la haute saône
c'est un outil qui est une véritable
école d'application pour faire des mises
en situation professionnelle est
vraiment adapté aux risques à couvrir
sur le département de la haute saône
ce bâtiment reproduit une habitation de
trois étages ils permettent aussi de
s'entraîner sur différents types de
toits des exercices que les pompiers
faisaient autrefois sur de véritables
maisons l'avantagent bien entendu de cet
outil c'est qu'aujourd'hui on a pu
reproduire ce que l'on retrouve dans la
réalité avec tous les outils nécessaires
pour former correctement nos sapeurs
pompiers en toute sécurité pour les
formateurs puisqu'on va pouvoir
contrôler effectivement toutes les mises
en situation professionnelle qu'on fait
et surtout on forme de sapeurs pompiers
à la sécurité qui doivent mettre en
place et en oeuvre sur les interventions
garantir la sécurité objectif principal
de ces stages de formation qui accueille
des pompiers de haute saône et des
départements voisins